so someone posted this graph on reddit earlier and this is absolutely wild
so basically each one of these categories they've looked at
like what the true proportion of the population for that demographic is
and like what americans estimate in blue
like how many people fall in that category
americans think that 20 of households have an income over 1 million
that 21 of the population 21 is trans
we think that 27 is muslim
27 is native american 30 is jewish and 30 lives in new york city
they also think 30 of the us is gay or lesbian
anyway you can like read up on down these categories
but like look at how big the gray is right
like the like our understanding of like american demographic reality
and the actual objective reality is like it is just enormous
like we are fundamentally wrong about like what america actually looks like